The Jordan Peele documentary that is four parts,
I recently watched that.
And I was always an admirer of yours,
but this documentary was not what I expected.
It also was a very long time ago. I was younger.
My perspective of it was different back then
due to age and maturity.
I mean, I grew up so fast,
but still, I think society was different then.
I think we are putting a new lens
on a lot of things.
Yes, absolutely.
How did we look at things?
Where do you think society is now
in comparison to where it was then?
I think society has help a lot
to actually looking through a different lens
because the 'me too.' Movement, we have a social movement.
We have campaigns, like the #WhyIStayed,
to help in social media.
So help, which actually social media
is a double-edged sword type of thing
because it's a good and it's bad
because we can find resources there,
I mean, with a click of your finger.
I mean, everybody, I mean,
who doesn't have a cell phone now these days, right?
So they can actually reach out for help
and look for resources.
But basically, society has changed a lot
based on the 'me too.' and #WhyIStayed campaigns.
And also, people have become more empathetic
and sympathetic with issues on domestic abuse,
sexual assault, and marital rape, all of these women issues.
And the new generations, also, bullying.
I mean, it's part of domestic abuse, so.
And we have a problem with that, too,
on social network, in the internet with Instagram
and Facebook and all of that.
So I think society has learned finally.
And education is the base, the core of everything.
So I think it's very powerful to educate,
to keep continuing the awareness and educate the public.
(upbeat pop music)